ومن ابرز الفيديوهات التي تم تداولها من
قبل رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في عام
20 22 كانت صفعه الممثل الامريكي والاسمث
في حفل جوائز في حفل توزيع جوائز الاوسكار
للكوميدي كراس روك عندما انزعج سميث من
دعابه اطلقها روك حول راس زوجته الحليق
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
شهد مونديال قطر لعام 2022 العديده من
الطرائف والاحداث الغريبه التي ضجت بها
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ويشهدتها مدرجات
وملاعب المونديال ولعلى ابرزها الاحداث
التي رافقت فرحه المشجعين السعوديين
بالفوز التاريخي على الارجنتين في
المباراه الاولى للاخضر واكثر لافته طريفه
كانت لشاب بن سعوديه عندما تسال اين ميسي
واصبح يرددها الجمهور السعودي على مدار
البطوله
وانتشرت بين المنتخبات الاخرى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بعدما خطفت والدته اللاعب المغربي سفيان
بوفال الانظار في مونديال قطر تداول
تداولت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي انباء عن
وفاتها في مدينه تازه المغربيه خلال
الساعات الاخيره ما استدعى ردا فوريا من
ابنائها لتوضيح حقيقه ذلك فقد نفى اثنان
من اشقاء بفار شائعه وفاته والدتهم عبر
حسابهم على انستقرام ونشره صوره قد كتب
عليها الحمد لله انها بخير وشكرا لرسائلكم
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم ونلقاكم العام
القادم باذن الله وكل عام وانتم بخير الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]